prioriser la valeur patrimoniale de
monuments ou se défaire du passé
colonialiste qu'il représente
le débat est relancé le déboulonnage de
la statue de john hemming dans nos
suscite des réactions polarisé mcdonough
desserte l'un des pères de la
confédération
mais c'est aussi sous son gouvernement
qui a été établi le programme des
pensionnats autochtones et adopté la loi
sur les indiens
c'est ce qui justifie le déboulonnage de
la statue à son effigie
selon un historien ça fait cent
vingt-cinq ans qu'il est là il est sain
à mon sens que de génération en
génération
chaque génération se questionne ans
quelle que soit sur la place qu'on veut
faire à certains personnages de notre
passé certains remettent toutefois en
doute les motivations des manifestants à
l'origine de cet acte de vandalisme
le monde a changé mais ceux qui font ces
choses là n'ont pas la formation
d'histoire eu il leur manque beaucoup de
formations d'histoire distincts que ça
qu'il chapeaute
l'image de l'imposante statue de bronze
décapité gisant par terre était forte
des politiciens d'un bout à l'autre du
pays ont dénoncé ce geste
le nouveau chef du parti conservateur du
canada et oui nos tours a tweeté que le
canada n'existerait pas sans john et mac
download et a poursuivi en invitant les
politiciens à ne pas plier face aux
activistes radicaux
de son côté françois legault a qualifié
ce geste d' inacceptable et s'est
positionné dans le débat en affirmant
que la statue devrait être restaurée
alors que c'est une approche contraire
qui a été préconisé à l'autre bout du
pays en 2018
une autre statue d'un mec d'un homme a
été retiré des marches de l'hôtel de
ville de victoria en signe de
réconciliation avec les premières
nations
la statue décapité a été déplacé ce
matin par la ville et c'est le bureau
d'art public qui coordonne sa
conservation
mais on sait toujours pas si la statue
contreversé reprendra sa place au centre
ville de montréal pour savoir la suite
il faudra attendre l'issue d'une
consultation entre des experts en
patrimoine de la ville ici marie-eve
bégin radio canada montréal